between 2008 and 2015
the 258 profitable fortune 500 companies
paid an average federal income tax rate
of 21.2 percent
of course the corporate tax rate during
this time period
was 35 but 21.2 percent
is still a significant amount however at
the same time
18 fortune 500 companies were able to
completely avoid paying federal income
tax
so how do they pull it off and what are
the other companies
and us missing
[Music]
well starting off the easiest way to
avoid paying taxes
is to avoid making money in the first
place after all
any percentage of zero is just zero
so if you make no money there's no taxes
to pay
now companies aren't going to just
settle with making no profits
simply to avoid paying taxes with that
being said
most rapidly growing companies don't
make any money
and thus don't pay any taxes during
their growth
this is not inherently a problem as long
as these companies
are truly investing in growth hiring
more employees
and contributing positively to the
economy this
isn't bad at all at the end of the day
all this money
will simply go towards the salaries of
new employees
however the problem arises when
companies
artificially create unprofitability or
lower their profits
one of the ways companies used to do
this was by paying out most of their
profits as salaries
to their executives for instance let's
say apple profited 10 billion
last year they could turn around and pay
their executives 8 billion
and say that they only profited 2
billion at the end of the day
and this is how much they would have
been taxed but
this loophole has been patched well
kind of in 1993 congress attempted to
close this loophole
but it wasn't very effective they did
cap
tax benefits at 1 million dollars per
executive per year
however there was and still is no
cap to performance-based compensation or
basically
stock compensation and top companies
make sure to take full advantage of this
for instance
alphabet ceo sunder pichai made 242
million dollars last year
out of which only 2 million dollars is
in cash
similarly apple ceo tim cook made
136 million dollars last year out of
which
only 10.67 million dollars was in cash
of course for companies profiting tens
of billions per year
like apple and google writing of a few
hundred million
or even a few billion as executive
compensation
is just a drop in the bucket but for
rapidly growing companies with little
profit to begin with
this strategy is very effective in
entirely wiping out the tax bill
for instance tesla recently awarded elon
musk
700 million dollars in stock
compensation
on top of this elon musk receives one
percent of tesla
for every 50 billion increase in market
valuation
and the relevant performance metrics and
for a company that's
only net profiting a few hundred million
dollars per year
i think it's clear how this can be
really beneficial
moving on we have the corporate
malfeasance deductions
if you or me get a parking or speeding
ticket
we won't be able to write these off on
our taxes
however many corporate violations are
tax deductible
some notable examples of these
advantages are with bank of america
and exxon after the financial crisis of
bank of america was charged for unfair
foreclosure policies
though bank of america had to pay up for
their predatory practices
they were also able to deduct this off
of their tax bill at the end of the year
similarly i think we all remember that
exxon valdez oil spill
after the disaster exxon had to pay a
hefty
1.1 billion dollars to settle all the
property damage claims
however at the end of the year they too
were able to deduct this expense from
their taxes
next up we have bank bailouts if
companies are losing money
and their investors are backing the
losses then
i think we'd agree that a tax break is
acceptable
however this becomes a bit shady when
companies lose money
and the taxpayers stomach the losses but
even here
it's understandable if the bailout money
is used to protect tens of thousands of
jobs
and keep the company afloat but where it
gets bad
is that companies can still write off
these losses in future years
for instance let's take a look at the
airline industry today
the government has given them tens of
billions of dollars to stay afloat
delta was burning through 50 million
dollars per day
at the end of april for our example
we'll say that this sustains for 100
days
and then delta suddenly becomes
profitable again
profiting 25 million per day obviously
in real life
they would go down to losing 40 million
a day and then 30 million a day
and eventually they'd work themselves
back to profitability
but that's okay as that's not relevant
to what we're trying to show here
so anyways in the first 100 days when
they're losing 50 million per day
they would lose a total of 500 million
dollars
but this is where uncle sam comes in the
federal government
happens to give delta the exact amount
of their losses
at 500 million dollars so at the end of
the day
delta actually doesn't lose any money
during the fiasco
but despite this they can claim their
500 million
loss on their next 500 million dollars
of profit
meaning that they don't have to pay
taxes on the next 500 million dollars
they make
considering that delta only gets back to
profiting 25 million dollars per day
which is less than the amount that they
were previously losing per day
delta can stretch out these losses and
not pay taxes for the next 200 days
so really delta didn't lose any money in
the first
100 days and they were able to avoid
taxes for the next 200 days
this is precisely the strategy that most
airlines will use for the next
several years and what many banks used
for several years
after the financial crisis anyways
finally
we of course have offshore tax loopholes
yeah many companies are established in
such tax havens to avoid taxes
altogether but one doesn't actually have
to be established there
to reap some of its benefits when
companies make profits
overseas these profits are not subject
to u.s
income taxes this law was established to
encourage companies to expand
internationally
and reward them for doing so and it
makes sense
if you produce a car in germany and sell
to a german
you shouldn't have to pay us income
taxes on this profit
sure you may be using intellectual
property that was developed in the us
but for the most part this law does seem
fair
however this has led to companies
developing some pretty sneaky ways
to abuse this law companies started to
register
all of their intellectual property
including patents and trademarks
in low tax nations let's take microsoft
for example
if they develop windows in the united
states and sell a copy
in india sure they don't have to pay u.s
income taxes on that
that's okay but here's how microsoft
abuses this law they go to a no income
tax zone
like the cayman islands and establish a
company called microsoft cayman
when they patent their new software
instead of getting a patent
in the us for windows 12 they patent it
in the cayman islands with microsoft
cayman now
microsoft cayman is the owner of windows
and any other company trying to use
windows 12 including microsoft north
america
has to pay royalties to microsoft cayman
at this point
when a customer in the united states
buys a copy of windows 12 for 100
let's say microsoft profits 50 a copy
so microsoft north america should profit
fifty dollars from the sale
but unfortunately microsoft north
america
didn't create windows 12. microsoft
cayman did
and they charged some hefty royalties of
for each copy sold worldwide thus
microsoft north america has to pay
microsoft cayman
45 and microsoft north america
only profits five dollars per windows 12
copy
sold within the us this doesn't affect
your bottom line
whatsoever as both microsoft north
america
and microsoft cayman are microsoft
companies
thus their financial report for
investors is not affected
however they only have to pay taxes on
five dollars
instead of fifty dollars this sounds
exaggerated
but this is exactly what's happening
with microsoft
for every dollar microsoft makes in the
united states
they send 47 cents to puerto rico
because
we all know that it was puerto rico that
created windows
and office and xbox and everything
obviously
it was the 10 employees working at
microsoft puerto rico
that are the powerhouse of microsoft the
other 160
000 employees worldwide just get fat
welfare checks from microsoft
because microsoft is so nice jokes aside
you get the point in the end all of
these loopholes cost the us government
between 100 and 200 billion dollars per
year
but don't get too worked up here giving
this money to the government
wouldn't really do anything as it's not
like they follow a budget
anyways what do you guys think is the
solution to this conundrum
comment that down below also if you guys
thought this video explained these
loopholes well
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one
you